this is China covered in pollution last
year but this year the skies are clear
that's because the coronavirus epidemic
had brought much of the country to a
standstill for several weeks causing a
huge drop in pollutants like nitrogen
dioxide a harmful gas that's emitted
when burning fossil fuel compared to
previous years it's below typical levels
if you close our factories or reduce the
amount of cars on the road you're going
to reduce the pollution levels and from
that we can deduce that the economic
activity has been decreased in early
February Chinese President Xi Jingping
publicly declared a People's war against
the virus that extreme measures like
shutdowns that prevented people from
returning to work were necessary but he
also cautioned that those efforts should
not jeopardize economic development now
a dramatic change in pollution over the
country suggest such striking that
balance could be difficult in the past
few decades China has grown to become
the world's largest coal consumer its
large manufacturing-based economy burns
ninety-five percent of the country's
coal making it the world's biggest
emitter of greenhouse gases usually
during the Lunar New Year most
industries wind down for a week and
power plants burn a lot less coal coal
consumption usually rebounds after the
week long break which means pollution
levels pick up too because the levels of
nitrogen dioxide in China are so high we
can easily detect that from space this
is what Wuhan the epicenter of the
corona virus usually looks like after
the holiday the city is a key producer
of automobiles electronics and heavy
machinery but this year the demand for
coal hasn't immediately rebounded since
many workers have been stranded at home
in lockdown cities and nitrogen dioxide
levels have dipped it's not just Wuhan
it's the same when you look at other
industrial powerhouses in China this is
what Shandong and Hebei usually look
like after the holidays
they're known for churning out
everything from textiles and medals to
petrochemicals but this year they also
weren't spared from the impact of the
epidemic while skies were clear in many
parts of China some cities like Beijing
are still shrouded and smog the city has
recorded high levels of air pollutants
these fine particles are created during
the chemical reaction of gases generated
from burning fuel heating systems and
Beijing's geography can affect this
reading but there's one huge source of
pollution that can't be missed
major steel makers around the capital
don't stop production during the holiday
because going offline is costlier than
running all year round so during the
city shutdown some factories continue to
produce steel Lee Hongmei is an analyst
who tracks a Chinese metal industry
because of the outbreak you know all the
normal pattern has been broken so the
construction sites are still in the
process of a resuming work that's why
there's your consumption slowdown and
delayed steel inventories are now at
record high levels because buyers in the
construction industry are demanding less
right now home sales were already
cooling before the virus now they're
below last year levels whenever you are
not so sure about your national economy
you're not so sure about your job
security about your income people
definite will be reducing expenditure in
investment in recent days she has been
touting efforts to meet economic targets
while containing the virus
like heavy stimulus to support banks and
tax cuts for small businesses but
analysts say it's not clear whether
these measures can help make up for lost
ground some factories are slowly
resuming production the pollution levels
that were observing from space are
beginning to increase which may indicate
that economic activity could be resuming
Beijing recently put out the first full
month of economic data after the virus
hit China the index tracks business
sentiment among manufacturing and
service sectors and it falls below the
lowest level recorded during the global
financial crisis an increase in the
number of infections overseas could also
put China's economy at greater risk
complicating efforts to me she's
economic goals for this year for now one
of the most visible indicators to see
how it all plays out might be just to
look up at the skies